[Music]
so have you guys ever got dressed up to
go to the movies no like oh i know where
this is going oh like spider-man
oh he did do that with this whole family
oh i thought it meant like in a date
like you know you go on a nice day or a
suit and you go out some people like
they go watch star wars and i've worn
the costumes i've worn a jedi road to
star wars yeah at least it's not
covering your head i don't know how
people sit there with a storm trooper
helmet on the whole [ __ ] movie
but hey that's their thing i guess power
to you yeah we did spiderman to the
homecoming movie oh yeah you and you and
and tiger were all dressed up
that's pretty fun um so there's a
problem happening right now with movie
theaters oh no
where uh a bunch of there's like a viral
trend where people are going to see the
new minions movie which is called rise
of glue in suits right suits wearing
formal attire what's the back story what
it's just a hashtag called gentle
minions and people are like yo we gotta
get dressed up for [ __ ] minions
and
and cinemas
uh have just banned this practice why
but they're also being like disruptive
right like it's not just like they're oh
we're gonna go watch the movie and be
normal about it like business suits how
are they being disruptive they're
talking during the movies and [ __ ] and
they're like having all their hands on
it it's a big joke yeah so they're just
doing it for the meme they don't
actually really want to go watch the
movie so they're [ __ ] it up for
everybody else yeah i did see this one
video these guys in suits were loading
up a [ __ ] trash can full of bananas
to go see the minions and i was like
what are they gonna do with that [ __ ]
go dump it out cause i swiped because
there was another thing with big ass and
like titties and stuff and i kind of
took some of that one yeah that took me
priority but i wish every movie theater
had like a sniper in the corner yeah
okay yes then if someone like misbehaves
they're just okay like
you know they lose their life the speed
of ryan's excitement is [ __ ] up one
of those
[ __ ] okay hot take hotty so if i were
ruler of the world yeah
if you need if you want to go watch a
movie in theaters you had to apply for
like a driver's license a license to go
see that [ __ ] movie i like that three
strikes and after three strikes you
can't watch a movie in theaters anymore
yeah you gotta wait for that [ __ ] dvd
like that yeah if i if you're [ __ ]
loud during the movie like i just
watched
a movie two nights ago and there's like
a dude that took a [ __ ] phone call in
the middle of a movie like no one
slapped yeah he was like oh yeah i think
i'm going to be like it'll probably be
like like maybe i'll be in at like 1am
or something
and i was like bro dude the people who
blast the light of day 2 all of a sudden
i don't know it's like your whole phone
lights up next to me and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on and bart cinemas
the guy would order a ch
boom yeah i'd be cool with that i feel
like i feel like you just i don't know
why people can't get all get on the same
[ __ ] page about just being [ __ ]
quiet during the movie like that's why i
don't watch like trashy movies in
theaters anymore because like just can't
[ __ ] stand trashy people so you don't
even like it when they like laugh loud
at a movie that's fine it pisses them
off that's part of the experience the
cathartic experience is different it
also depends on what kind of movie
you're watching like if we're [ __ ]
watching like an art house movie or
something like that and they're just
like talking to each other laughing
about a joke they're having amongst
themselves and i'm like shut the [ __ ] up
but if it's like in reaction to like a
thing in the movie like a bit in the
movie then yeah everyone should be like
you know
yeah those people don't need to die no
those people are fine yeah but the other
people the ones that are [ __ ] talking
i don't have a whole [ __ ] family
sniped bro what about boom headshot what
about the end the movie you guys all
know how this goes right
the waiter comes over and they're like
standing over you to have you sign the
check and [ __ ] the waiter's dead boom
boom gone why don't you go and pay the
bill outside
i don't know dude the [ __ ] person's
hunched over me at the end of the
[ __ ] movie like oh did you order a
rack of lamb or something while you were
eating and let's have a ribs oh
yeah i had a bib on i was having ribs
smacked on the ring
boom yeah especially if it's a marvel
movie the waiter better not show up
until after the credits and then that
little sneak peek
after
you know i feel like we were those guys
though when we watched fast five
when uh when when vin diesel was getting
married in a tank top
we were laughing at all the scenes that
we shouldn't be laughing at but i
thought everybody would laugh that's a
fast movie but people were taking it
seriously so those ones those ones what
i would do i i like i like giving people
a chance so and a warning so that one is
just the electrocution chair so if we
started laughing like we did yeah yeah
yeah yeah
oh no
i should be laughing well electrocution
means death just like a zapper oh it
looks like a taser like a tase like a
taste like a teasy taste electric chairs
usually death no i mean like a little oh
[ __ ] okay all right
because i think instead of a sniper what
we should do is just install guns in the
back of the chair right and someone can
have a keyboard here and then oh this
guy's [ __ ] having a conversation two
of them yeah but you think that
you guys really think the democrats are
gonna let us install guns in all the
movie theaters
that's true that's why we moved to vegas
exactly
yeah call these cucks [ __ ] talk about
let us have sniper
yeah libertarian theaters they would let
us this sounds more like an
authoritarian tyrannical movie theater
which i love it's one of joe jorgensen's
policies
i still understand that everybody
wearing suits like what kind of what
does that uh say with the movie the joke
is that they're taking it too seriously
because it's a minions [ __ ] sequel
bro
so they're like this you would never
dress up for this if someone [ __ ] up
with the minions too for me i think i
start [ __ ] them up i'm a big fan of
the minions yeah i think i turn around
and start slapping their faces sitting
there trying to watch rise of gru and
then all of a sudden you know these
little jokers [ __ ] around a little
joke i think the thing that i empathize
with the moviegoers is that they're like
like people are taking their families or
whatever and then people like swearing
and like being loud during the movie
like that would piss me off that's why i
always bring a butterfly knife to the
movie theater oh because if someone's
[ __ ] talking some [ __ ] i gotta do
this thing and threaten them and if
they're like laughing at me then i
[ __ ] start stabbing the [ __ ] out of
them and then they die but if they're
cool then you just run that thing
through your hair
that's right oh sexy as freak dude thank
you for reading these dm's dudes [ __ ]
crazy
if i was like the owner of the uh movie
theater and like a [ __ ] ton of people
show up to like buy tickets so i might
be like
hey don't tell anybody you're not banned
from this one though it's like i agree
already right i'm like yeah
well yeah especially movie theaters are
struggling right now yeah like if
they're dressed like that i'm not
banning them for dressing like that no
that's not the thing if they if they do
some weird [ __ ] in the theater dress
like that then i'm like get out but it
has nothing to do with what you're
wearing it just puts you in the uh i'm
going to judge you more because you're
wearing that what's a more realistic
eco-friendly non-violent way of handling
the situation because i was you mean no
boom headshot way no
less killing more teaching right i was
thinking about like remember showtime at
the apollo where the clown comes and
brings the big hook if they [ __ ] suck
and then they hook them out right
ejection cheats let's get that right
here dude
i think humiliation humiliation is good
that's good you ain't that funny bro
shut up like flogging or something the
public vlogging yeah what about just
like like toad darts like
tokens
oh
oh that could just go to sleep i think
those kill you though or the i don't
know [ __ ] gummy worm darts or
something some kind of tranquilizer
salamander but if they just have to sit
in like the popcorn machine for the rest
of the movie ejection seat
juxta because
just ejects out of the seat hmm what's
the last movie you guys saw i saw every
single top gun baby oh i want to see
that stuff top gun pretty cool man
i saw [ __ ] doctor strange last in the
theaters yeah dude that's like what like
five years ago no no no no the most
recent one [ __ ] guy oh christ part oh
my gosh bart doesn't
do you not see ads in vegas you want to
see billboards you see bus stops and
[ __ ] dude
i think bart sees that he's like they
still got this ad from five years
he didn't see the two jokers bunch of
jokers
doctors
like 40 years old
[Laughter]
jurassic park jeff
they gotta swap these ads out they're
crazy
it's a mint condition 40 year old
billboard
so there's there are signs that say due
to recent disservices disturbances
following the
gentle minions trend any group of guests
in formal attire will be refused entry
for showings of minions rise of group
okay
so if you if you show up for something
else maybe for top gun in a flight suit
your gucci
you think a bunch of like mormons or
something or [ __ ] uh what are they uh
uh jehovah's what the witnesses will
show up and like they'll just get
rejected i hope so yeah they got to wear
other bicycles i hope to god but they
don't ever wear a blazer i always see
them with like
business yeah shorts and a helmet helmet
yeah a lot of shorts and a pocket
protector and a tie they look like they
work in the mail room the marmon's
though they they definitely are they're
foreign everything you do is pretty cool
i was a pretty obnoxious uh moviegoer
friend to watch me you would be dead
yeah in my world because
i grew up in a in a more ghetto
neighborhood and all of us just talked
at the
like we interacted like with the screen
like that was just the thing to do and
no you're just [ __ ] and you don't
even know it no no one told the whole
movie theater does it wow this is why
arclight was the [ __ ] event it was
the best i do love arclight the
experience is the best i'll pay an extra
10 15 for that experience are they done
though are they well what's that explain
experience quiet people
are like it's because like you're it was
one of the first years where you could
actually choose your seats and [ __ ] yeah
you could choose your seats
it was more expensive so it's like if
you really want to go see a movie you
like we're putting down extra money to
go have this experience and they
actually have ushers that'll be like yo
get the [ __ ] out of here i like rich
ryan he's sick rich ryan
arclight is more for i think like for
filmmaker lovers or film lovers
so like even the guy comes out and
that's like a little like speech about
them oh yeah that [ __ ] like close down
and turn into an amc though right really
well what about the one
no the arc light was bought out yeah
arclight has a chain was bought out by
somebody else he didn't survive the
pandemic no cinerama dome was going to
get demolished and i think someone else
and no commercials yeah only
uh previews commerce yeah no commercials
you know they don't go
barely had anything no commercial like
so only the good stuff only previews in
the movie no no 30 minutes of
commercials before the movie starts but
don't you like the polar bear drinking
the [ __ ] coca-cola oh bro and the
[ __ ] roller coaster going through
popcorn land
the first time that i saw that you know
that last one
the last popcorn explosion no one gets
me like whoa
the old ass analog phone the funniest
kids in the theaters always put their
[ __ ] arms up during this oh do they
dead they're dead yeah yeah kill them
boom
you guys don't like it when the
celebrity goes oh hey turn off your
phones because we're watching it you
mean nicole kidman nowadays i i would
shoot the screen the [ __ ] screen's
dead
you guys i'll stay together i'll stick
with the trash theaters you guys can go
to arclight i like nicole [ __ ] but that
ad does annoy me check out the theater
at the station casino all the floor your
feet is stuck on it yeah my kind of
casino bro you don't know if it's soda
or [ __ ] i'm off
i'm also sick of walter white and jesse
trying to sell me all kinds of [ __ ]
with the tequila yeah they're making
tequila yeah but they're still holes
they're in commercials together for all
kinds of [ __ ] i'm like please just leave
me alone now guys
like you guys are ruining it
because they they're so great together
but they were ruining it i had no idea
that the tequila i didn't even know that
they were going they were sampling at a
costco's that's kind of cool actually
that's what i'm saying there you love
tequila
have you tried their tequila i haven't
tried them
all right we'll try it we're going to
love it hopefully i hope we love it i
hope we love it heisenberg tequila
no it's called like dose ombres i think
oh that's appropriation
[Music]
you